what's going on I'm younger from the UK
and I've been traveling across America
with BuzzFeed I'm on Vans Warped Tour
I'm from a place called Doncaster in the
north of England I've been recording
videos so far out May fiends on toast in
a strip club a and seafood in Long
Island and going all across America
trying out foods from your country
[Music]
mantasy glass they look incredible
that's the best title I it holy day off
guys it's nothing well I love the crispy
skin
it gave me a well nice meal at Magic
City in Atlanta so I'm gonna ask the
chef if I can make them beans on toast a
little swimming from where I'm from
brother and Brittish be Tonto you're not
try that road
got it yeah listen
so this may be one of probably the most
bizarre situations I have ever been in
in my entire life like I just been in
the middle of the strip club eating
chicken
like what if it's just jokes what the
chicken is in Topman Atlanta is a thumbs
up from me best chicken wings we're out
but King go nuts
so this is my date for the day
how are you sugarplum
I'm hungry - I'm starving I'm Hank
bloody Marvin
let's go ready
Drake the cheers
because I got someone in it looks
amazing right normal you saw the hot dog
with mustard mousse has got like
everything to it man it's got so many
layers and I know my can god I can't
leash ache after disease asleep
it tastes like a chocolate cake in like
liquid form so I just had party Lowe's
hotdog and cake shake tonight attempt
from me made by the beautiful yourself
you have deep this year no I'm not
deeply sure that's next
that's next yeah let's go so me and Adam
Arena in Chicago we're gonna try
deep-dish pizza but a very very very
first time I can't wait I'm excited are
you scoop hi my name is Maggie and
welcome to luminaries pizzeria home of
Chicago's best deep-dish Chicago style
pizza may look so big like an inch mom
[Music]
one more bite and I'm one more bite I
said for a second
another one my mom who invented this
really damn tired Alex is out to take a
piece of pizza off me because man how
about let's go on stage tonight so I
want to keep it and take it away from
once a start once torn up yep ahh bra
brain freeze mom yo so I'm a snow ASIS
and bolt and all with a boys yeah
there's like a beach on the ground sick
hi my name is Erin we're here at Sno
ASIS in Baltimore and we have snow balls
with finely shaved ice it's not ice
cream it's not custard but you can get
ice cream on it look at this a nice
slide
[Music]
go home with boy insane get my nuts gone
without chocolate snow yeah how do you
even do that matters is sick
I mean gonna a few moments later I am
like sugar rushing right now my head is
like sugar fuels me don't give dumb
sugar pick up two bolivars thank you for
teaching me the ways of the snowball
Menelaos enjoyed it very much didn't way
it's very really nice I'm rushing off my
not right now on sugar I probably not
gonna sleep so I check in at 3 o'clock
this morning I'll see you later
Wow so that's it man I'm literally
speechless I've gained about 10 stone
but whatever thank you so much america
the food's been great peace out
[Music]
for more Latino content right here
[Music]